Okay, so let me show you where we're going with all this.
We're going to zoom ahead on supervised classification.
So here we have the driving data set,
750 points now that we've drawn in our scatter plot.
And the goal is to draw a decision boundary that will help us distinguish which
terrain we need to go slow on and which terrain we can go really fast.
So that means being able to draw a boundary that looks something like this,
where we're able to divide the two classes.
And here's what that's going to look like.
So we have our decision boundary that we can draw in here between our two
classes, and for any arbitrary point, we can immediately classify it as
terrain where we have to go slow or terrain where we can drive really fast.